Actually, I really wanna talk to you about
Get Real with Diabetes,
because we touched on that with mama
the last time you were here.
But you're doing a campaign, this is personal for you.
You're bike riding around the city.
There's this whole lifestyle going on.
And I want in on the information.
Well, I was diagnosed with type 2 diabetes 21 years ago.
I was the first person in my family to be diagnosed with it,
then my mom.
And then we found out that my dad
had been living with diabetes undiagnosed for over 20 years.
And I subsequently, lost my father
to complications of diabetes.
So that's why I partnered with Novo Nordisk five years ago
to talk about this.
And little known fact, I didn't know this,
that cardiovascular disease, heart attacks and strokes,
I'm four times at greater risk to get it,
to die from those things than you are,
because I'm a type 2 diabetic.
And those are things that we need to address
within the community.
And so we have a campaign,
it's called Get Real About Diabetes.
And our website is getrealaboutdiabetes.com,
and you can go there and get the information that you need
to learn how to prevent the disease.
And if you are diagnosed with it, how to live with it,
and it doesn't have to be a death sentence.
And that's what we're here to talk about.
That's what we're here,
to give information to the community,
so that they can spread that information
within their families and within their communities,
so we could help hopefully one day eradicate this.
I think you are, I know that you will.
Thank you.
Is it true that you ride your bike all over the city?
I do, I do.
How?
I bought a bike 10 years ago,
12 years ago when I was living here, I bought a bike,
and just started.
I ride the train, this is how you get around.
I walk the streets, I ride the train and I ride my bike.
And that's what you do when you live in New York.
And so I'm an unofficial New Yorker.
Well, I love that you're here in the city.
Yeah, love being here.
I'm now a New Yorker and I'm so proud,
although I would not attempt getting on a bike
because I just know I would be road pizza in one block.
(Anthony laughs)
One block, Anthony.
Maybe you can give me lessons.
I can imagine, I will, I will.
We'll get a bike and we're gonna go,
this is what we'll do, we'll ride in Central Park together.
We'll just be easy, we'll start easy first.
We'll ride in the park.
Okay.
We'll get on a little bike path, we'll ride in the park.
Will you?
I'm serious.
I'm serious, we can do that.
I would love to.
We can do that.
That's a date.
All right, you got it.
All right, thank you.
It's like, every day I walk by the city bikes
and the internal dialogue is, you're a big wuss.
You should mount that thing and be bold and ride.
(audience cheers)
That's one way of looking at it.
All right, well, maybe-
Mount it.
Mount the bike, Drew!
Okay.
That's right.
Stop being a wuss, mount that sucker and ride!
(Anthony laughs)
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Okay, now, you're the host of "To Tell the Truth."
Yes.
And you have your hot hands in so many honey pots.
I do, I do.
You know, I saw an opportunity
to give my mother an opportunity to live out her dream.
She always wanted to be an actress
and it never happened for her because she's horrible.
(Drew laughs)
Mama.
No, so she's my cohost on the show
and we're going into seven seasons now.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Yeah.
Thanks to you guys.
And what more fun than to do this with your loved ones.
(upbeat bright music)